with the firing of the Attorney General
and in my view the improper installation
of an acting Attorney General the
president now has this investigation in
his sights
well with that utterance outgoing
Senator Jeff Flake has perfectly summed
up his career in the upper chamber
despite zero evidence of any threat to
the Muller investigation flake is now
saying he'll block the confirmation of
highly qualified conservative judges
across the land here now to react is
former Whitewater Independent Counsel
and judge himself Ken Starr and former
assistant US attorney and Fox News
contributor Andy McCarthy Andy you think
this bill that flake and his newfound
Democratic buddies are offering is
unconstitutional explain well all of the
authority in the Constitution in article
2 all the executive authority is vested
in the president in our system
prosecution is an executive power you
cannot pass a constitutional bill that
essentially takes away the president's
executive power and the president's
power to lead the executive branch and
reposes it in someone else whether it's
the prosecutor himself or some other
branch of government to oversee him so
the reason people oppose this Laura as a
legal matter is that it's
unconstitutional but as a factual matter
as you suggest this is pure
grandstanding and theatrics under
circumstances where there's no reason to
believe there's any threat to the Moller
investigation and Judge Starr I think
about the phenomenal many many cases
young lawyers who have been waiting for
confirmation appellate court judges
district court judges military court you
just want to hold them all up well it's
terrible it really is and I agree fully
with Andy there's no foreseeable threat
there just isn't I understand that wait
who is this mr. Whittaker guy and what
did he say when he was a CNN commenting
but he's now the Attorney General of the
United States so it's regular order and
as you well know Laura there are
processes within the Justice Department
so he will be consulting on these kinds
of actions that could affect the
investigation so he's not a solo
performer I want to talk about what's
going on with the Whitaker appointment
and you you have some conservative
lawyers including Kelly and Conway's
husband and others were saying this was
completely unconstitutional and illegal
to nominate or to appoint him as Acting
Attorney General because he's not been
confirmed by the Senate I want to play a
montage of some of them let's watch
Whitaker is effectively a constitutional
nobody I think Matthew Whitaker's
appointment was unconstitutional illegal
and just plain wrong I just don't see
any legal opinion that that is that I
can take seriously that counters this
judge well the office of legal counsel
is the set of constitutional lawyers
they are paid to look at these kinds of
issues and they concluded at a very
careful memorandum it's 30 pages long
people may disagree with it I think it
happens to be correct this isn't whether
it was wise to appoint mr. Whitaker it
is was it lawful I think it clearly was
under a specific statute passed by
Congress that permits the President to
do exactly what he did and I want to go
to you on this this is what on Shep's
show earlier today Judge Napolitano
was saying about this very issue and the
OLC is ruling on the Whitaker
appointment I was very disappointed to
see the lawyers who work for Matthew
Whitaker go back to 1866 and look for a
precedent there to decide whether or not
it was lawfully appointed I don't care
what happened in 1866 because the
Congress changed the law in the 1960s
and said whoever runs the Justice
Department has to be nominated by the
President and confirmed by the Senate
because we put too much power in their
hands that kind of power can't go to a
political hack okay political hack yeah
he was a federal
you know the US attorney in Iowa but
your thoughts on what Judge Napolitano
said there yeah I was disappointed to
hear my friend Judge Napolitano suggest
well I was disappointed to see that he
doesn't seem to really understand how
the Office of Legal Counsel works but
you know what they do is things like go
back to the precedents that go back to
the founding of the country into the
Constitution particularly Laura when
it's a constitutional claim being made I
understand Judge Napolitano is point
that the statute is from 1998 but this
the statute is not what people are
complaining about it's whether this
application of the statute is
constitutional or not and one of the
ways that constitutional lawyers go
about making that analysis is to go back
through the history of the United States
and see where this situation has come up
again and how it's been handled judge
you think the mother is going to wrap
this thing out the special counsel up by
the end I think so the indications are
that we're moving along but apparently
there may be a couple more indictments
along the way but I think we're ready
for it for there to be a wrap yeah I
like Jerome Corsi and Roger Stephanie
came to me like perjury process yeah
well this was don't lie to her to the
prosecutors now that idea not a good
idea guys thank you so much